we need the rain we could use more will
we get it
we'll see a lot of people are saying boy
bring it back bring it back we need more
storms like last night skies cleared
through the morning hours but we're
starting to see those
clouds building again over the mountains
and we'll see what we get but the stage
is set for a repeat performance did you
see if you were out looking at the
storms or saw them from your windows
that incredible shelf cloud that was
just moving through the valley from
north to south this one captured by just
jazz who sent it in looking out at star
in las vegas boulevard up in the north
and it's a big cloud that precedes
usually big thunderstorms and very
strong winds and that's what we got last
night a lot of great pictures of it out
there on social media and chantelle
johnson captured some wonderful video
looking out across the valley all lit up
with our beautiful city lights and some
great lightning last night now these
storms could be very ferocious we had
some trees down with 50 to 60 mile an
hour winds and we may see that again
temperatures are in the 90s we have a
lot of moisture out there high dew
points some of these rain totals were
phenomenal more than a half an inch of
rain from henderson to out there near
the clark county wetlands
two thirds of an inch in mesquite almost
an inch in the mountains and you can see
we had some wonderful rain totals from
these thunderstorms now coming in from
the north northeast they are usually
accompanied by very strong winds that's
just what we saw last night latest radar
over to the east and the north of us
we've got the same storm flow coming
from the northeast to the south and we
might see some of those strong winds
again with thunderstorms that could be
forming over in southern nevada tonight
but boy things are really starting to
pop in western nevada right now as we
expand the national picture more heat
for the pacific northwest and here is
the flooding in kentucky more showers
and thunderstorms hitting st louis which
had tremendous flooding at the beginning
of the week same storm track over and
over again in those areas 100 degrees is
what we're looking for we are looking
for the chance of thunderstorms this
afternoon into tonight and that's about
a 30 to 40 percent chance so please if
you have outdoor plans tonight please be
close to a safe place to get in from the
dangerous lightning and maybe those
strong winds we're going to keep the
chance of thunderstorms in the
afternoons for the rest of the week
temperatures near 100 degrees through
the weekend into early next week looks
like we could see storms all the way
into the beginning of august heather